[MUSIC PLAYING]
STEPHANIE VALENCIA:
Come on up, Luis.
[APPLAUSE]
LUIS MIRANDA: Thank you.
STEPHANIE VALENCIA: So
welcome to Talks at Google.
We have about 800 folks on the
Livestream from Mountain View,
Seattle, Chicago, New
York City, and hopefully
Washington, DC, my home office.
It's a treat to have
you, Luis, here today--
LUIS MIRANDA: Thank
you, pleasure.
STEPHANIE VALENCIA:
--and Luz, your wife,
Lin-Manuel's mom,
here with us today.
And that you've been a
part of the conversation
that we've been having
around bringing students
into this experience and how we
can use and leverage technology
to do so.
A little bit about your
background, which I think
is super fascinating.
And I think as we think about
how your life and experience
and legacy connects to the
work that Lin-Manuel has done,
we'll talk a little
bit about that today.
You're from New York City.
LUIS MIRANDA: I'm
from Puerto Rico.
STEPHANIE VALENCIA:
Puerto Rico, yes,
but has spent the last
30, 40 years of your life
in New York City working
for three mayors--
Giuliani, Ed Koch,
and David Dinkins.
You were the founding
president of the--
LUIS MIRANDA: And thank you
for making me 10 years younger.
44 years in New York.
STEPHANIE VALENCIA: 44 years.
OK, it must have
been an old bio.
You were the founding president
of the Hispanic Federation,
one of the country's largest--
and what I would
say most impactful--
Latino organizations
out of New York City
serving Latinos in New
York and in Florida.
You founded a political
consulting firm
called the MirRam
Group where you've
worked on lots of
successful campaigns,
including Senator Clinton,
and Senator Schumer,
and Senator Gillibrand
in New York.
So we're so glad
to have you here.
And we really want to talk today
a little bit about politics,
history, and legacy, and
really community empowerment,
and kind of the role that
you've played in that
and how the work that Lin-Manuel
is doing through his work
is helping to do
that for so many.
So I was mentioning to
you in the Green Room
that we first met in 2009
in the summer of 2009
when President Obama
nominated Justice
Sotomayor to the Supreme Court.
She handed me a
list of people who
were going to help
get her confirmed,
who were going to help
to provide validation
of her kind of contribution
to the community in New York
and nationally.
And at the top of that
list was your name,
along with about a dozen
other very prominent New York
political leaders.
So let's start there.
How did you become so
involved in politics,
in community empowerment.
LUIS MIRANDA: I don't recall
ever not being in a campaign.
My family, it's a very
political family in Puerto Rico
more so then than now.
We had-- those of you who know
a little bit about Puerto Rico--
there is always politics.
Everything is politics
in Puerto Rico.
And we had people in different
parties who had run for Senate.
And my uncle is the founder of
the Puerto Rican Independence
Party.
So we were always in a campaign.
So it was logical then when
I came to New York at 18
in '73 to get involved,
initially in the Puerto Rican
Socialist Party.
I sold "Claridad" which was
the paper of the Puerto Rican
Socialist Party in the streets
of the lower East Side.
And then sort of little
by little, sort of main
streamed myself into
democratic politics.
So I don't recall ever not
being involved in a campaign.
And that's why my
views are also a bit
to the left than that
most of my contemporaries.
STEPHANIE VALENCIA:
Do you remember
what that issue was that
you read in "La Claridad"
or what really drove you
to want to get involved?
LUIS MIRANDA: Every issue.
Injustice just pisses me off.
[LAUGHTER]
It doesn't energize me.
It pisses me off and it makes me
have to do something about it.
Many times my wife
will tell me someone
it's been unjust in the
street in some dispute.
I want to intervene.
And she's like the
hell, let it be.
So probably injustice is
what pushes my buttons.
STEPHANIE VALENCIA: Right.
And I think that
that's part of what's
so beautiful in your
relationship with,
and influence, on Lin-Manuel's
kind of creativity
and his career, because we're
all products of our family
history and the legacies of
our parents and their struggles
and what they
fought to be, right?
And Lin-Manuel has talked about
your involvement in politics
and how that made him more
awoke like to what was happening
in the world around him and the
injustice that was happening
in the world around him.
And so talk about how you
think your civic engagement
and political participation--
I even read that I think you
recruited when Lin-Manuel was
a lot younger to do a jingle for
one of the campaigns that you--
LUIS MIRANDA: You know,
we always worried--
we don't worry
anymore-- but we always
worried how he was going to
pay his next meal and rent.
STEPHANIE VALENCIA: He
could have been a lawyer.
Imagine that.
That would have been a
travesty for society.
LUIS MIRANDA: I thought
that Ruben Blades
was the perfect example.
Graduate, law, Harvard,
and a singer, a famous one.
I figured and I kept telling
you could be like Ruben Blades.
You could go to law
school become a lawyer
and then have this gig
until that gig takes off.
The gig took off
before the law part.
STEPHANIE VALENCIA:
Were you ever worried?
LUIS MIRANDA: Oh, we
were always worried.
And that's why any time I had
a gig in my office, something
that I knew he could do, we will
tell him to write this jingle.
Write this piece of music.
And then we will pay him.
Now I actually
have the copyrights
to all of those that
I paid 500 bucks
and they're worth much more.
STEPHANIE VALENCIA: I want
to know which candidates have
their-- they should say that.
LUIS MIRANDA: He remembers he
did jingles for Eliot Spitzer.
And when Eliot--
who's a friend--
got into a bit of
trouble and had
to resign from the governorship,
Lin-Manuel asked me,
didn't I do a jingle for him?
I said you did.
STEPHANIE VALENCIA:
Well, so folks
start getting your
questions ready,
because we're going to
open up to audience Q&A
here in a minute.
But you know you spent
a lot of your time--
you helped to found that
Hispanic Federation,
as I mentioned, one of
the country's largest
Latino advocacy organizations.
What do you think
is the current state
of play for the Latino
community in New York
and in the United States.
LUIS MIRANDA: Oh, please,
don't let me start.
Remember I told you
injustice pissed me off.
Trump is the embodiment
of injustice.
So I just think that this
guy's such a nightmare.
It's unbelievable
that we're still days
away from a hundred days.
I was counting the other
day, 1,340 more days to go.
I think I'm going to do a
clock or something in my room
to sort of go one by one and
sort of feel a little better.
It sort of reminds me a bit of--
I don't know how many
of you read "One Hundred
Years of Solitude" Gabriel
Garcia Marquez, a 1967 novel.
And the families,
the Buendia family
where he creates his
own Macondo town.
So I feel all the time
like I'm in my condo
that Trump creates his own life,
his own reality, his own shit.
And somehow we're
supposed to swallow it so.
All of that to say that
we must redouble efforts.
When Luz and I, when my wife
and I, were having breakfast
this morning, I was
telling her that I always
thought that, OK, I am
as busiest as I can get.
But every time something else
comes up and I take it on,
and somehow you're able
to do it because we're
able to do many, many things.
And I think that every single
one or us during the next 1,342
days need to do even more to
move the community forward
and fight this avalanche of crap
that this misguided government
has on us.
Not that I have an
opinion about it.
STEPHANIE VALENCIA: Tell
me how you really feel.
So before I open
it up to Q&A, I'll
ask one last quick question.
I think-- and I've kind
of seen you do interviews
with Lin-Manuel and you and
your wife interacting with him.
And I think it's a
very-- and we were just
kind of talking back there
about your daughter and son
as kids and this beautiful
relationship of, I think,
admiration and respect and what
really seems like friendship
that you guys have.
Which is a beautiful
thing to see.
It seems very grounded and
kind of where he comes from
and what you fought for.
That's really beautiful.
So back in 2009, kind
of the famous anecdote
around when he first debuted
"Hamilton" at the White
House at a Poetry Jam with
President Obama and the First
Lady Michelle Obama, from
a father's point of view
or a parent's
point-of-view, talk
about how you have seen him from
"In The Heights" to "Hamilton"
to writing music for "Moana"
and now Mary Poppins".
Like what have you seen
about his work style
and how he struggled and
what is from a fath--
LUIS MIRANDA: First,
my shot was not
supposed to be the number
in the White House.
I had gotten a call
from David Axelrod
with whom I had done campaigns.
And he had just finished
doing the Obama campaign.
They said the First Lady's
have having this night
and can Lin-Manuel do a
number from "In the Heights"
because he had gotten the
Tony for "In the Heights"
And so I told Lin-Manuel, you're
invited at the White House.
They want a number
from "In the Heights."
He's like, do you think that
I could do this number that--
and I stop him and I
said, no, you can't.
They want a number from
me "In the Heights."
But do--
And I have learned--
and more and more
as he gets older--
to trust his judgment.
He is such a mature soul.
And I say, you know what
I mean, it's my own crap.
What is it that you want me
to send to the White House?
He said so I'm going
to send you the lyrics.
And I sent you the music to
this song that I just wrote.
So I send it to them.
And they love it.
Not only did they
ask him to do it,
but he closed the night with
"My Shot," which had never
been any where before.
But it tells you--
not only that I
trust his judgment--
but through his own creativity
that he knew many, many,
many years ago, now we
know where "Hamilton" is--
that there was something
special about this music.
So I have learned
through the years
to sort of trust his judgment.
And when I fight
back, and I do often,
half of the time he ends up
convincing me that his way
it's the best way for him.
And he will-- because
he's actually very sweet
that way-- he will
say, for you, this
is the best course of
action, for me, this
is the best course of action.
So we have grown to sort
of respect each other
and do things our way.
Sometimes agreeing,
sometimes disagreeing,
but always respecting
that this is the path
that we're going to follow.
STEPHANIE VALENCIA:
Would you say
you agree most of the time,
half the time, or less than half
the time.
LUIS MIRANDA: I think that
his way, for him, it's
the best way 90%
percent of the time.
He really has a very
good sense of who he is,
of how he conducts himself, and
what works for his audience.
Sometimes I send
him a tweet before I
tweet because I don't think.
I just watch some piece of
news and someone pissed me off.
And I write a tweet.
Sometimes I send
before I should.
But when it involves
him, I actually
send him the tweet to sanitize
and sort of read first
before I tweet it because
I trust his judgment.
For him, he's right
90% of the time.
STEPHANIE VALENCIA:
Well, congratulations,
because as a parents that's
what you want, right?
For your kids to
have good judgment,
you want them to be confident
in who they are and grounded.
And so congratulations
to both for that.
LUIS MIRANDA: Thank
you, thank you.
STEPHANIE VALENCIA:
Any audience questions?
In the room?
In the back.
Into the mic up front
so they can hear you.
AUDIENCE: So you've worked
on a lot of Clinton campaigns
through your whole career.
And I think that one of the
more energizing things that's
come out of this last election
is that a lot more people now
are considering running for
office for the first time
or our communities that
haven't been politically
been represented in politics.
For people who are
thinking about getting
involved, even running for
office for the first time,
what would you have as advice
for a first time candidate?
LUIS MIRANDA: That
they should run.
You know you get
good at repetition.
When you do the same
thing many times,
you get better at it
every single time.
So sometimes you don't win.
It really doesn't matter.
But you begin to
create a machine.
You begin to create a cadre
of people who help you,
who believe like you.
You begin to get good at
speaking in public, which
is something that I'm
surprised so many people have
difficulties with.
But running-- it's like for
my son, it's rehearsing.
And rehearsing makes perfect.
Running makes perfect.
And you get better
every time you do it.
If people have the confidence
to do it, they should do it.
It doesn't matter if
they come in last.
There's also name recognition.
If you don't have a
lot of money to run--
and most cities in
the country don't
have campaign finance
where they help candidates
with dollars to run--
running several
times is the best way
to be known in a
particular community.
But also to be realistic.
You know don't start
running for president
before you run for
state assembly.
Also find your place
and what you think
makes the most sense
at a particular time.
But I believe that running also
makes people better and makes
more people wanting to
be engaged politically.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
STEPHANIE VALENCIA: Any
other audience question?
Yes, please come up.
Be Somebody may need to
help you with the mic.
AUDIENCE: Hi, my
name is Sidarth.
And did you encourage
Lin-Manuel Miranda
to get involved with politics?
LUIS MIRANDA: No.
Because I will fail.
And I fail at enough things at
62 I don't want to a big one
to my repertoire of failures.
Lin-Manuel's call in life
is not elected office.
He gets interviewed all
the time and he said, oh, I
don't like politics.
Not true.
He loves politics,
because politics
it's the art of getting
involved in the day today
and making a difference.
And that's what he
does every single day.
But he will never run
for elective office,
though he will always
be involved in politics
particularly in the whole
fight for immigrant rights
that we're going
to have to fight
in this country over
the next 1,342 days.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
LUIS MIRANDA: You're welcome.
STEPHANIE VALENCIA: Part
of yesterday's announcement
was the virtual
reality experience
and the six kind of places
of the experiences that
can bring students closer
to the "Hamilton" experience
without leaving their classroom
or their home, which I think
is very cool.
And I think it's a
great example of how
you can use technology to open
up access and opportunities.
So what do you see as like
the role of opportunity
of technology to open up some of
these opportunities to the arts
or to certain communities
who may not necessarily
have the resources to access
or experience certain things?
LUIS MIRANDA: I'll
start by saying--
and that's why we're doing the
"Hamilton" Education Program.
I probably told Justin
and Daisy 1,000 times
when we were having discussions
of how Google can get involved,
there's nothing like an
audience in a theater.
There's nothing
that changes that.
The connection with the
actor, the connection
with the audience, the
feelings that sort of come out
of that relationship in
"Hamilton" for two hours and 50
minutes.
It's unique.
But we realize that at the end
of four years, $20 millions
into this initiative,
we're going
to be able to bring
only 200,000 high school
students to the theater
to have that experience.
So anything that can help bring
that experience to many more
people, it's very important.
The virtual reality that
we just saw a little bit,
it's incredible.
It's places that I have now
visited in all this "Hamilton"
tour that our lives have become.
I tell people all the
time I never realized
that this Puerto
Rican family was
in charge of Hamilton's legacy.
If someone would have said
to me in Vega Alta when
I was 17 years old, you know
the guy on the $10 bill,
you're going to be responsible
for his legacy, I would say,
right.
But.
So seeing the virtual
reality of the places
that I have now experienced
in this "Hamilton" journey
that we have been in for a
while is a magnificent way
of kids and people
to realize this
is the house where Alexander--
the only house he owned--
and this is what the house looks
like in the middle of Harlem,
because the house is in
the middle of Harlem.
So mixing that with interviews,
with YouTubes, with the music,
it's the second best
to being in a theater
and experiencing the magic of
an audience-actor relationship.
And anything you
guys can do, welcome.
STEPHANIE VALENCIA: Great.
Other questions?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Hey, my name's Becca.
Within my Latin social
circle, two conversations
have come up a lot.
One, the term LatinX
and then there's
this controversy around
Justin Bieber showing up
in a Luis Fonsi song.
And they seem really
trivial, but I
think underneath is like this
struggle of our generation
to preserve our roots
and like our heritage,
but also bend to the
needs that we have.
And I think it's so
important now, especially
under this Administration,
that we find a balance.
And I'd love to just hear
your thoughts on what you do
or advice around that topic.
LUIS MIRANDA: And I
start with what I said,
Lin-Manuel is right 90%
of the time for him.
Because he's looking at it from
his perspective, from his age
cord, from his reality.
And as much as I
try hard to do that,
there is always a difference.
I'm the result of
my own experiences.
And I think I'm also trying to
understand younger people is
the only way to run
campaigns, because you
have to begin to put yourselves
not only your age cohort--
though unfortunately so far,
they're like 50% of the vote.
That's why people don't
think about younger
people and younger
needs, because when
you look at the electorate,
you say, you know what?
If I get 60% of the 55
plus vote, I'm home free.
So as long as we begin to
vote like the normal curve
and represent that in
the right percentage,
that's what's going to happen.
And I believe that more and more
you need to preserve history,
but you need to show
it and present it
the way we are right now.
And I think that that's
the beauty of "Hamilton."
I remember when I
was 18 years old.
I went to a "Sound
of Music" performance
at New York University.
I came here to study.
And Maria Von Trapp was black.
in this performance.
Because it was student
theater and it was a vanguard.
And I'm sitting
there after seeing
the "Sound of Music"
at 18 100 times,
this is just Maria Von Trapp.
And it took me a while to wrap
my head around the possibility
that Maria Van Trapp was
just an entrepreneur who
sang beautifully and
tried to save a family.
It didn't matter the color
that Maria Van Trapp was.
And that's what "Hamilton"
does for this generation.
No longer George
Washington is going
to be a white dude with white
hair for generations to come.
The most exciting moment
of all this "Hamilton" trip
that my wife and I and my
family have gone through
was being in the White House
listening to Chris Jackson,
a black man, with
a George Washington
picture, an actual
portrait in the back,
singing a George
Washington song.
And that's what
you're talking about.
It's how do we actualize
for this generation what
our history is?
STEPHANIE VALENCIA: Well
in yesterday's show,
all three male leads were black.
And it was not lost on
me thinking about all
of the kids in the room and just
what they must been thinking
experiencing the
show in that way
and seeing themselves on stage.
And you know what that does
even just for that 200,000 kids
who will see it and
experience the show.
LUIS MIRANDA: And in the music,
that is not Broadway tunes.
So that it's not
only that they're
a multi-colored diverse,
but they're also
seeing in the vernacular
that young people understand.
I remember for
"In the Heights" I
did a lot of numbers in my
head how long will it run.
How much to recoup
your investment?
Because at the end of the
day, I'm also a businessman.
How much to recoup your
investments and all of that.
And understanding that the
average Broadway theater goer
is a 55-year-old
woman from suburbia
earning an average of $140,000.
So when you think about
the audiences on Broadway,
"Hamilton" should
have never made it.
But it did.
And we sat there,
Luz 100 times--
I don't even know how
many times she has gone--
STEPHANIE VALENCIA: 106?
LUZ MIRANDA: 36.
LUIS MIRANDA: 36 times.
And we sit there
with many people
who are like our
contemporaries in terms of age
enjoying this feast
that can not be
more different from their taste
and from their daily living.
So there's something
special that you
can do to bring different people
together to appreciate art.
STEPHANIE VALENCIA: And
that's one of the things
that you're spending
time on is how
to expand the
audiences on Broadway
to more diverse audiences.
LUIS MIRANDA: We
didn't have a lot
of money for
Lin-Manuel and Lucecita
so we usually went to
Broadway once a year.
So, of course, we took poor
Lin-Manuel see Les Mis at seven
because we wanted
to see Les Mis.
At the end of the day, you know
all the age appropriate things
that you guys think
about today, you're
bring your kids
to school-- ah, we
didn't think age appropriate.
We wanted to see Les Mis.
We're going to drag him
along to see Les Mis.
So we went to see a
show like once a year.
We had a lot of show tune LPs,
records in the house which
is how Lin-Manuel and
my daughter Lucecita
learned their appreciation.
But it's difficult
to dish out the money
to go and see a Broadway show.
So anything we could do-- we
have the "Hamilton" Education
Initiative as part of Viva
Broadway that I'm on the chair
for the Broadway League,
we bring families.
Sort of we select three shows
and then an entire family
comes to see the shows.
And there is then a talk
with the actors at the end,
just like you saw yesterday
at the Orpheum here.
So any way that we could
encourage and give access
to theater, we will.
STEPHANIE VALENCIA: Great.
Let me just ask if we have
other audience questions,
please line up at the mic.
"In the Heights," how many
folks have seen "In the Heights"
also?
How much of that was based on
your experience, your family
experience?
And what he--
LUIS MIRANDA: It was a
bit autobiographical.
Quiara Alegria Hudes,
who wrote the libretto,
it's partly also her story.
She also comes from a
Puerto Rican family,
but in Philadelphia.
Lin-Manuel from New York.
But when we were looking--
we were both NYU students,
that's where we met.
And we were living in
university housing.
And when Lin-Manuel
was born, we were
sort of the typical Puerto Rican
family, five in a one bedroom
apartment.
We sort of figured
out we probably
need to get out of here.
If not, they were going
to kick us out anyway.
So when we started
looking at neighborhoods,
Washington Heights reminded
me the most of Vega Alta.
It was a Latino
neighborhood where
people are in every window
checking what everyone
is doing, where everyone is
sort of in everyone's business,
where in the bodega in the back,
there were slot machines so
that you didn't have
to go to Atlantic City,
but there's some illegal
way of playing the numbers
in the neighborhood.
And I said this is my
perfect neighborhood.
I'm in New York, the A
and the 1 come up here
and I could go anywhere in New
York with these two trains.
So that was Lin-Manuel's
neighborhood.
He was there.
We moved when he was one.
And that's where he grew up.
So obviously that had
an incredible impact.
When you see the
generational dilemmas
that are presented
in "In the Heights."
AUDIENCE: Hi.
So I'm actually
asking this question
on behalf of my teammate
who's in Sunnyvale.
Her grandmother actually
lives in Washington Heights.
And so her question is
how can we as Googlers
use our products to better
connect with the Latino
community, including for
older Hispanic generations
like her grandmother,
who really don't use
social media that much but--
and who can't afford
to see "Hamilton"
but who really feel strongly
about making a change
in this political climate.
LUIS MIRANDA: Well people don't
have to tweet and Facebook
or create content for you to--
though all of that is welcome.
And if your
grandmother wants to do
a YouTube of how
much she hates Trump,
I think we all can
agree to retweet.
STEPHANIE VALENCIA: Yes.
That would go viral.
I think that would go viral.
LUIS MIRANDA: So I will
encourage her to do that also.
But I think we should
use anything we can.
I remember when we were in the
midst of trying to get the US
Navy out of Vieques,
Puerto Rico,
it was a big struggle
with the US Navy taking
this island, which is also
a municipality, outside
of the east coast
in Puerto Rico.
And there were many,
many, many fights.
And we did a survey
to see what people
were willing to do from writing
a letter to making a phone
call to going to a demonstration
to doing a number of things.
And what I learned and
continue to learn in practice
is you have to meet
people where they're at.
You try to move them to do more.
You should never be content with
just allowing your grandmother
to just talk to her friends
or talk to them on the phone.
You've got to push
them to do more,
because that's the only
way social change happen.
But from in Washington
Heights, when its made first--
I don't even know
the day I'm in--
AUDIENCE: Monday.
LUIS MIRANDA: There is a
big rally Sunday and Monday,
pro immigrant, against Trump.
So if she is in
Washington Heights,
I would encourage her
to go to the rally.
And people really need to
do anything they can do.
I thought we had
agreed-- we have
been doing a lot of
fundraising in social media
with sweepstakes, virtual
sweepstakes, and all of that.
And we were going to do
sweepstakes for ACLU.
And then the weekend,
of the madness
occurs in every airport and ACLU
in three days get $25 million
from little
donations from people
who were outraged that
this shit was happening.
And they just clicked and
gave whatever they could.
So helping our causes
is another way in which
everyone should participate.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
STEPHANIE VALENCIA: Justin.
AUDIENCE: I've got to
move this up for myself.
Luis and Luz, thank you
so much for being here.
There were some great
tweets yesterday
between Lin-Manuel
and our CEO Sundar.
I wonder if you were
CEO of Google for a day
how might you steer this ship to
bring more equity in the Latino
community?
And I think about Stephanie's
work in DC and the work
that we do at google.org.
We'll be together at the Latino
Community Foundation Gala
tonight.
So there's all these
ways that Google
is trying to lean into
the Latino community
and do good things.
But if you were Sundar
for a day, how would
you try to get this
company-- and like what
issues, what topics,
how would you
want us to put our
weight behind some these?
LUIS MIRANDA: First
thing I will do
is that I will tweet
denouncing Trump.
So that's the first thing,
the first item on the agenda.
I believe that this
Administration is so bad
that any business
that allows a picture
to be taken with this
pig should be denounced.
So again, that's the
first thing I would do.
After that tweet, that would
take all of 15 seconds,
it's only 140 characters--
STEPHANIE VALENCIA: You
still have the full day.
You still have the full day.
LUIS MIRANDA: I still have 23
hours plus to do other stuff.
I think that you are
involved in the right issues,
because every company
has to pick their lane.
You should not be doing
what your lane is not.
Whatever company
is in that lane,
that's what you should be doing.
But you should be
involved, I believe,
initially in education because.
At the end of the
day, education is
the equalizer in this country.
I am who I am, Lin-Manuel
is who he is because we
got a great public education.
And less and less public
education opportunities
for our kids to be great.
It's amazing to me,
god, I wish I could not
talk this much what Trump.
We'll call him X from now on.
That X budget cuts 0.022%
arts, humanities, and history.
It's not even a freaking
penny in the budget.
But they're so mean.
Now they just add a cut for
the sake of adding a cut.
So education is obviously a lane
in which you guys have a lot
to offer, a lot to offer,
because you have so many tools
to enhance that
process in a unique way
that that ought to be your lane.
And then candidate-wise,
part is what
you should be doing
anyway in education,
and also checking the ties,
what's happening in the world
right now and do that
from the education lane.
STEPHANIE VALENCIA: Great.
Last audience question.
AUDIENCE: Take the
mic down a little bit.
Not that tall.
LUIS MIRANDA: Six inches.
AUDIENCE: So my
question is actually
more related to the
Latino community.
So my name is Olga
and I actually
run our Latino Employee
Resource Group here at Google
called Hola.
And you know I would
love some words of wisdom
of even sparking this interest
inside of our communities.
I think typically
we see that there's
some people that are very
passionate about these issues
and others that haven't
quite found their place yet.
So I would love--
hopefully we have some Hola
members watching this too--
to hear some words of wisdom.
LUIS MIRANDA: I start by
probably there's not enough
of you Latinos in this company.
AUDIENCE: Nope.
LUIS MIRANDA: And
I'll start by saying
if you look at our
society, white people
marry whites, Asians marry
Asians, blacks marry blacks.
And once in a while
there are intermarriages.
But they are the
small percentage
of who we are as a society.
And that's what happens.
White people hire white people.
And you really need to
get out of your skin
to create a diverse
working force.
And I believe something that I
didn't do that your CEO needs
to do is you incentivize
your managers
for having a diverse workforce.
If you have an entire
white male force,
you're not getting a
freaking bonus this year,
because that is not what we
should be doing as a company
and as a society.
So certainly there is, I'm sure
Hola can use many, many more
members.
And it's up to managers
to do their job.
And it's up to us--
unfortunately it really
should not up to us,
it should be up
to Human Resources
to fill this room with Latinos.
But they're not going to do
it, because for the most part
they're white.
And they're hiring people
who look like them.
So it's our responsibility
to then constantly be saying,
I have this friend,
I know this person.
You give him an
interview, please.
She's really good.
He's really good.
And you plead a little.
And you sort of
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
just to ask for mercy
from your counterpart.
And then they're good.
But then our responsibility
is to be great.
Not just good, just
to be great, to show
that we could do the work.
That they didn't hand
us some mercy job
because we're Latinos,
but because we
are good in what we do.
And that's our responsibility.
When I see a kid who's doing C
or B, I'm like man, you suck.
You're a bright kid,
you should be doing A
and you're doing C. Well, the
system, the teacher, oh, god,
enough of [SPEAKING SPANISH]
to explain why we're not
as good as we should be.
So that's our
responsibility to do that.
And Hola, as it is
in so many companies,
it's really to
create this sense--
because sometimes
you feel isolated.
And I went to NYU, oh,
my god, to a PhD program
in clinical psychology.
Did I feel lonely?
So Hola, it's your
support system.
And it should exist.
It should have the
resources to expand.
And I'm glad you're here.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
STEPHANIE VALENCIA: I want
to give an applause to you.
[APPLAUSE]
And I think just given
the changing nature
of the demographics
of a country--
like Silicon Valley and tech
can't ignore this issue.
It won't fix itself.
And I think that given
the fact that one
in three children in pre-K today
are Latino for the first time
ever, I think it was
last year, more than 50%
of new births in the United
States were minority.
So this is coming, it's here.
LUIS MIRANDA: And
little things like
I remember I was in the
Nielsen Advisory Council.
And they couldn't find Latinos.
Every time someone tells me
that they can not find Latinos,
I want to shoot that person.
Because I never want to shoot
myself, should that person.
Then I look at the
universities where
they were recruiting from.
I'm like you got to be joking.
There is an
association of Latino
where Latino students are 40%
or more of the graduating class.
The same thing in the
African-American community.
Just begin to look at
those all the universities
and begin to look at
the world differently.
It doesn't have to be
the Ivy Leagues only.
Many of those universities
turn out great students.
So it's little
things like that that
begin to change
the rhythm of what
happens in corporate America.
And this one they did.
And then they had
to recruit more.
STEPHANIE VALENCIA: And
we talked a little bit
about this earlier, but
how through "Hamilton"
you know Lin-Manuel has kind
of changed the way that we
perceive and look at history
by who he casts in his shows.
And part of another kind
of key part for Google
on the education piece is we
work with the entertainment
industry to try to
change the face of who
are playing engineers
on television,
who's playing scientists.
And so a Latina can see a
Latina engineer on television
on one of the major networks
or on a YouTube or a Hulu show
and to see that that
can be them, too.
And I think that
that's really important
too that in the kind
of mainstream media
that we see those also
change not just on corporate.
LUIS MIRANDA: In 1982, I
was Director of Research
over the National Action Council
for Minorities in Engineering,
NACME.
That was before most
of you were born.
And the struggle was how do we
bring more African-Americans
and Latinos just
into the schools.
And schools were
willing to admit them.
Then how do we keep them there?
And how do we assist them
in graduating and not
feeling isolated?
But clearly media now has
this unbelievable impact.
Lin-Manuel says
it best that if he
wanted to be in a
Broadway show, he
was going to have to create it.
Because he did not--
he had to be a gang member in
"West Side Story," "Zoot Suit,"
or "Capeman."
Those were the only
roles for Latinos.
And they were all gang members.
Said if you don't want
to be a gang member,
create your own show and then
you could be whomever you want.
And entertainment
has that power.
And you guys have that
power to sort of show
a very different face of who
different communities are.
STEPHANIE VALENCIA: So
we're almost at time.
I want to show one
really quick last clip.
And then we'll end a little
bit more on a high note here.
Just give me a second.
This may bring back
some memories for you.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC - "FOOTLOOSE"]
We're not going to
watch the whole video,
but just to give you
a little bit of a--
LUIS MIRANDA: No, there
are thousands of these.
STEPHANIE VALENCIA: I know.
[END PLAYBACK]
So this was one
that-- you're right--
one of many videos that
in my research today--
or research for today
I was looking through.
There was also a really
great one of the pushcart--
LUIS MIRANDA: The
push carts wars.
STEPHANIE VALENCIA: Where he--
you were the cameraman and
you, Luz were a protester.
LUIS MIRANDA: Half of the
people in that video are dead,
my grandmother and
all them, their dead.
STEPHANIE VALENCIA: But I think
I guess my just question to you
to end on that higher
note is clearly you
guys gave him the
space to be who he was
and what he wanted to do and
be creative in your home.
And you guys were active
participants in that,
whether you wanted to be or not.
And so, looking back
at that with you,
I know that Lin-Manuel
talked about how Luz always
used to say that he would
win an Oscar some day.
And he took you to the
Oscars this year, right?
LUZ MIRANDA: Yes.
STEPHANIE VALENCIA:
And so would you
say what when he was
that age and forcing
you guys to be his camera
person and his actresses
in his little shows,
did you predict
he would be where he was today?
LUIS MIRANDA: It's very diff--
we always knew that
he will be big.
In my house, we have
the two extremes.
My daughter is an engineer
and a finance person.
And so she needed that space.
And we needed to
give her that space.
And Lin-Manuel was that dorky
guy that you saw on that video.
And we needed to
give him that space.
We had to go the full spectrum
to make sure that we met them
where they were as kids.
And we always knew
that he would be great.
You can never imagine that
it will be this madness where
we worry if we buy a little
house in Puerto Rico how
much security it should have.
We never thought that those
would be worries of ours.
That no longer can he take
the subway, which he loves.
He learned how to
drive, literally
he got his license the day
before he went to college
because he had no other choice.
He always took the
subway in New York.
He's a New York baby.
So to that level, I don't
think anybody ever thinks
that their kids will be there.
I guess if you're very rich
and very powerful you take it
for granted.
But we both come from
humble beginnings.
So that was never
the expectation.
Now we expect that from
all of our grandchildren,
the poor kids.
Anything else will be failure.
STEPHANIE VALENCIA: So we're
going just to wrap finish with
a couple fill-in-the-blank
questions.
I just want you to
say kind of what first
comes to mind for all of them.
LUIS MIRANDA: OK.
That's fine.
STEPHANIE VALENCIA: What's
your favorite "Hamilton" song?
LUIS MIRANDA: "My Shot."
STEPHANIE VALENCIA: OK.
In 10 years, I see Lin-Manuel--
LUIS MIRANDA: Having three kids
and spending time with them.
STEPHANIE VALENCIA: In 10 years,
I see the Latino community--
LUIS MIRANDA: Better
than we are today
because this new generation
has much more kohonas
that my generation had.
STEPHANIE VALENCIA:
Last question or last
fill-in-the-blank, I
hope my legacy will be--
LUIS MIRANDA: That the future
generations of Mirandas
are committed to social change.
STEPHANIE VALENCIA: Well you
have done a great job at that.
LUIS MIRANDA: Thank you.
STEPHANIE VALENCIA:
So thank you guys
for both being here and for this
greater partnership with Google
and the "Hamilton"
Education Project.
And welcome to Google.
Thank you for everybody who came
in and for those who tuned in.
LUIS MIRANDA: You guys
have a cool place here.
STEPHANIE VALENCIA: And you
can hang out here all day.
Let's go raid the snack cabinet.
So thank you.
[APPLAUSE]